welcome back so I'm really excited today
to introduce to you this new roadmap
document control for societal scale
challenges roadmap 2030. this is a
publication of the IEEE control system
society
and it's just a really fantastic
document that outlines what are the
major societal challenges that we humans
face today and in the future and how is
control theory well posed to be Central
in solving and addressing these
challenges so I'm really excited to
introduce this to you I'm going to put a
link to this document in the description
below so please click it download it and
read this for yourself I'm going to give
you the high level overview of what
you're going to find in this document in
this video
so this was a collaboration between a
pretty large number of some of the
world's leading foremost experts in
control theory uh edited by and
organized by professors Anna Swami
Johansson Pappas and so you know I I
recommend you know pausing this or
downloading this and checking this out
it's really a star-studded group some of
my heroes in control theory are among
this author list people I respect uh and
work with and it really highlights that
there is a coalition kind of this group
of diverse opinions coming together to
really outline and address what are
these societal scale challenges and how
can control theory help okay so really
excited to walk you through this
this video is going to be the
introduction where I'm essentially just
going to tell you what the various
chapters are how this is organized and
give you a little teaser for what you're
going to see in the subsequent videos
Okay so this document it's almost a book
it's about 250 pages long and you know
it's it's a pretty hefty read but it's
also tractable so there's been a lot of
polishing and streamlining of these
ideas so that it is focused but very
comprehensive so this video covers kind
of the introduction this is uh you know
chapter one of this this roadmap is an
introduction this video gives you just a
high level overview of what the topics
are and I'm going to have short focused
videos uh kind of demoing what you're
going to see in at least a number of
these chapters if not all of them
so chapter two uh this is really kind of
the core motivational foundational piece
of this roadmap looking into what are
the societal drivers that are driving
the future uh you know the future
efforts in in this field so things like
climate change something that we need to
address that control theory is going to
be Central we're going to need to
measure we're going to need to model
we're going to need to predict estimate
and control the system to uh to deal
with climate change so that's that's an
example of a societal driver things like
biotechnology and biomedical technology
how do we deal with pandemics and
diseases very topical now those are the
kinds of societal drivers that we're
going to talk about here and this is a
pretty hefty chapter I want to say this
is almost a third of the entire roadmap
a little bit less than a third of the
road map but really this is the set of
common issues that we humans face that
we think control theory is well poised
to be Central in addressing okay very
very important very interesting read I
highly recommend it
uh chapter 3 technological Trends talks
about what are the trends in uh
technology more generally than control
theory at large that are driving some of
our Advanced capabilities that we think
you know in the the next 10 years or so
are going to really be affecting how we
develop control theory Solutions uh to
address these societal challenges so
technological Trends could be things
like uh the rise of big data and
artificial intelligence this is not
specific to control theory this is a
societal Trend a technological Trend in
general but it's going to change How We
Do control theory and how we do modeling
and things like that things like the
electrification of everything so
increasingly every aspect of our uh our
you know industrial Energy power grid
everything is becoming more electrified
that is a huge technological Trend uh
The Internet of Things autonomy robotic
systems these are General Trends in
technology that again are going to drive
our Advanced control capabilities and
how we're going to be thinking about
solving these societal level challenges
the fourth chapter this is one that's uh
kind of near and dear to my heart is
emerging methodologies and this is
really kind of emerging methodologies in
control theory that are developing these
Advanced capabilities things like the
interface of machine learning and
control uh autonomy cyber physical
systems Robotics and so so this is
really focused on what are the emerging
methodologies uh that we as control
theorists have access to kind of driven
by these broader technological trends
that we can use to start solving these
societal level challenges
so I hope you can see that there is you
know some some thought process behind
this abstraction and the modularization
of these chapters they really do build
on each other so chapter two is highly
motivational chapter three is you know
what's happening in society at large
with technology chapter four is more
focusing on kind of how this is applying
in control theory uh capabilities
chapter five I think is really really
important and interesting too which is
uh technology validation and translation
so how do we actually take these control
Technologies these kind of emerging
methodologies and how do we start to
scale them into being able to solve
these societal level challenges this
advocates for the need for Benchmark
problems for validation problems and
validation data sets we're going to need
our control theory solutions to be
trustworthy explainable verifiable
especially when we're using machine
learning techniques uh you know in in
these kind of hybrid machine learning
control systems and so this really talks
about what are some of those challenges
to actually scale this up and verify and
validate and actually get these into you
know industrial scale Solutions
chapter six again one that's very very
uh close to my heart is education so I
contributed to this chapter a little bit
and the idea here is
if we want to have these solutions to
the societal level problems we need a
Workforce of Engineers who have the
training to actually use these
methodologies to solve these problems so
we want our Engineers to have these
basic capabilities in control theory in
machine learning in you know validation
and translation so kind of everything in
this roadmap we need to be beefing up
our educational efforts so that we're
training the next generation of
Engineers that can actually you know
enact and develop these Technologies for
for Global good for societal scale
change okay so very exciting and
something again you know I'm very
passionate about and again I want to
just point out I'm going to have
hopefully videos on you know at least
most of these chapters if not all of
these chapters to give you kind of a
little sneak preview of what you're
going to find but you're going to need
to actually download and read this
document to get the full depth I'm going
to give just very topical kind of
high-level anecdotes from these chapters
but there's a lot of uh substance there
that I'm not going to be able to cover
in this short time
uh the last kind of you know big chapter
is chapter seven ethics fairness and
Regulatory issues which addresses things
like you know what are the actual issues
with deploying societal scale control uh
solutions to solve these challenges one
of the things I really like and I've
seen in lots of the chapters in this
roadmap is this focus on fairness and
equity in how we actually deployed these
control Solutions so if you think about
the equitable distribution of medical
resources and medical care that's
actually a control theory problem that's
a constrained optimization problem and
so I just really like this kind of
modern perspective that we need to be
thinking about fairness and ethics and
Equity when we are dealing with these
large-scale uh control theory Solutions
so that we don't only help a few uh and
not not everybody okay so really kind of
a neat perspective here and an important
one too
and then finally chapter eight is kind
of a conclusion summary recommendations
how do you take this all together what
are next steps how do we get started how
do you you know kind of join the cause
so really excited to walk you through
this again this is a collaboration with
a number of amazing researchers that I
respect very very much and so I hope you
get as much value and kind of education
out of this and inspiration too out of
this as I did all right thank you